ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dillon show I'm very excited to be here
with
um the guy who put me on my first
podcast in La nobody put me on nobody
cared nobody would look at me
um and this guy said come to my house
and we'll do a podcast and thank you so
much it's worked out it has worked out
yes I'm A good scout yeah there's a
couple people where I I like where I
silently take credit when they when I
see them blow up since what it is is
like it's got to be like when you are an
actual talent scout and you you see
someone that just makes you giggle by
yourself yeah and then you watch them
blow the [__] up and then you're like I
knew I'm good I knew I can pick Talent
yeah well I appreciate that let me ask
you a question one um
what do you think do you think we all do
this like does podcasting go on forever
does this eventually stop does this does
this become like when we like younger
Comics now are not starting them yeah
they're just doing Clips
um that's the [__] thing they're
going out with short forms if you can
get heckled these days you're the
luckiest comic out there God damn it man
I'm so jealous if I had had Clips back
in the day because I was chaos on stage
right I was chaos take my shirt off
drink six beers on stage yeah welcome it
welcome chaos right man if we had
cameras back then so does this what
happens to this medium eventually I'll
tell you I'll tell you the idea of
having a podcast uh a conglomerate like
a like an umbrella yeah where you start
podcasting that's dead right that's that
the idea of having like a company I
think it's dead I agree um I've had a
lot of people come and asked to be part
of my network and I'm like I don't have
a network I do me right I do me that's
all I give a [__] about I don't want to
lose any of my attention about me social
media companies I think they're going
away I think people are starting to go
no no I'll just get that person I want
them to work for me I think I think
everything's going in-house I'll tell
you where I'm going yes I'm making this
you're a guy that you're always kind of
on
the new thing like you're always you
focus a lot on whatever the new thing is
going to be in comedy like you you were
doing Instagram stories years and years
and years ago showing me how many people
were watching your story showing me how
they could buy tickets you were on all
of that [__] I wonder sometimes I I
sometimes wonder if it's because I'm not
as talented as other people I pay
attention a little more and I work a
little harder yeah and I try things I
also don't mind failing but um but yeah
I mean I remember watching Joe and going
I mean there's so much meat left on that
bone yeah I mean with all the all the
things he does and I look Joe wants
privacy and he's a bad example but I
remember going if I was Joe if I could
have that Outreach I'll tell you what
I'd do right and that's the way I looked
at it right and right now what would you
do so if you had like his level of power
oh dude I mean would it be I mean first
of all I'd be I'd be doing more movies
I mean I know that he doesn't want to do
that but I think that's funny [__] well
he's got a bunch of jobs right he's got
the UFC he he's dad he's a comedian yeah
he just does the podcast
so but but it's for sure there's maybe
more yeah I would do he could do he is
lazy I think Joe he's a little lazy I
think that's kind of what we're getting
at I think what we're getting at is
Rogan's kind of like a little bit lazy
is that where we're going I think he is
I mean I think he is you look what it is
okay work out more what does he do talk
to someone for three hours that's it I
know and then smokes weed and drinks and
this whole spending time with my family
I'm not buying it enough I asked him his
daughter's name the other day and he
stumbled the world should know their
name yeah they should be monetized yeah
every member of that family should be
massively big on social I only trust a
man who puts his family on Instagram if
you're not on Instagram then he's not
around them it's a good point God Joe
really is he does the opposite of you a
little bit with that word he does he
wants more the Privacy he might be gay
is it maybe is that what it is and this
is his beard this could be his beard is
absolutely I wouldn't be shocked I I
think most people who don't put their
kids on Instagram are gay
your kids are not all over social media
you're gay you're gay if you're not
trying to monetize every interaction
with your family if you're not trying to
[__] yes
you're a gay man it sucks when you
realize that videos of your daughter go
are more popular than videos without
your daughter yeah then you're like yo
Isla yeah I gotta sell tickets in
Cleveland yeah get over here stop having
teenager problems but it's you so where
are you going you just said everything's
going in house meaning that every things
are going in house the cameras are going
in the house it's like Epstein and the
cameras are in the house oh I just
bought a new house yeah and built it out
to just have all production in there
amazing so we have now is it just so you
can live 24 7 with people filming it I
said to my wife can we please put a bed
in here because I could be I don't I'd
love to just could you monetize your
sleep like could you I've already
thought of it I've already thought of it
I've already thought of it how great
would this be okay yeah
it's a dream podcast so we get you to go
to sleep it's it's we work with calm the
the app right and we get you breathing
and get you into sleep and then as you
go to sleep
then I take over and I go all right
we're in and I I poke I take you through
dreams that night really great dreams
and you can scroll and be like I want to
fight dragons tonight so now what do you
mean by you take them through dreams so
so you ever listen to a podcast while
you sleep and also I always fall asleep
to a podcast especially the best and
then all of a sudden you're like you
have a dream that like it's you and
Hitler and you guys are trying to clear
out the Eagles Nest before and you're
like God damn it I shouldn't have
listened to the [__] Hitler podcast
so you're doing the inspiring your
dreams nicer and then I'm like hey grab
that coke
grab a Coca-Cola we're gonna be thirsty
fighting dragons oh and we put ad sales
in there so you're subliminally getting
into their mind because because that's
the last Escape people have from the
culture of advertising is sleep and we
need to end that I had a dream I had a
dream I was listening I listened to um
to a podcast called This Day in History
I think it's it's on noiser okay and
they did an ad read in the dream and the
ad reach in the in the in the podcast
and the ad reads showed up in my dream
and I I woke up and I went that's the
future right you if if you can find
podcasts that put people to sleep yeah
some would argue that mine does right
then those and then you put ads in
people's heads while they while they
sleep and then they wake up and they're
like it's like program it's like MK
Ultra programming Ultra programming yeah
like while they sleep and you just can
like he does oh Tito's you're gonna wake
up tomorrow at 9am and have a glass of
Tito's yeah and then you get in there
who cares what your wife says Jimmy Dean
sausages yeah that'd be great before we
fight a dragon sausage sandwich in there
so a nice runny egg an american cheese
God I'm [__] hungry now so now you're
what is the next iteration of you could
because you're doing fully loaded you're
out on the road with a bunch of comics
doing minor league baseball stadiums
doing Minor League Baseball stands
starting at Forest Hills we ended the
gorge and we're doing Arenas and minor
league baseball stadium you're one of
the biggest Arena Comics in the world
what are you now number three uh three
or four four four four who were the
first let's do it we're the first three
uh Sebastian fluffy and Joe Coy you can
get them you can get it I'm going after
Joker you can get I'm going head-to-head
with that [__] you can get him
as the nation of the Philippines the
whole nation
if I could just
isolate a minority to fall in love with
me yes we're going head to head right I
need I need one I'm looking at the mongs
fluffy dead the monks what are the monks
they're the Hill People in Vietnam are
they drunks no the hmongs am I saying
I'm wrong you need Native Americans
because there's there's not enough of
them but they're drunks and they live on
reservations and they eat horribly and
they may love you and you gotta teach
them like yes your land was stolen but
it's a party yeah I could I would dude I
partied with a Native American one time
yeah on Crow territory Crow Nation and
flying in his van and when I'm on a
motorcycle trying to catch up with them
we're gonna go do where custard's Last
Stand was yeah and I'm flying on my
motorcycle cop pulls me over I'm like
I'm [__] dead I'm dead I've been
drinking I'm on a motorcycle I'm going
90 miles an hour funnest maybe the all I
kept thinking was I'm gonna hit a cow
right that's what my whole thought dude
turns around
leave this land right now to the cop
he's with me ignore him let's go wow and
I looked at this cop like sorry white
guy yeah it's Sovereign land due to
Sovereign land I [__] could get down
on Sovereign
to be Sovereign land well you have to be
a Cherokee or a chicken chicken I was in
Oklahoma City there's a lot of them
Chickasaw Cherokee yeah you know you
gotta have you gotta have some bloodline
or you gotta Trace some so I don't know
that was that Elizabeth Warren she tried
yeah you know I'm part native American
don't say that right she goes I can say
it I said no just it's better not to say
it right I can say it I am the grannies
grannies Nemo yeah with something my
mother always used to say it my mother
used to go I feel like I'm part Cherokee
and my mother looked like me in Drag and
I'm like this there's nothing more
offensive than this comment coming out
of your fat white mouth that's the best
so now you've got three did you ever
think of it it's amazing you've got
three guys ahead of you yeah in this in
in the terms of putting people in seats
it's crazy
is there is there a moment if you if you
get if you beat them if you get to
number one and you're the top comic in
the world I go back to clubs immediately
well then what well I mean what the [__]
it's like I'm already stressed out about
it what do you do I'm already stressed
out about what I do now because right
now I'm get like
like there is no like what like what
what else happens I mean I made it I
made uh well I made a hundred thousand
dollar bet with someone
that I would never uh do Raymond James
Stadium
uh because I was like I was like that'll
never happen and the guy was like dead
seriously like I'll bet you 100 000 it
happens I mean I ultimately I guess
you're Kevin Hart you have to pay you
have to pay him yeah if I do it but I'm
never gonna do Raymond James I mean
where is that in Tampa like how much is
it how many people [__] 75 000 I mean
but like that's heavy That's Heavy it's
like I mean here's the deal I mean you
know what what am I saying um I don't
believe in negative talk I believe in
positive talk I put it in the universe
let's let's let that happen let's let
the machine comes out Memorial Day
weekend I hope it does great I hope it
does great for a lot of reasons number
one if the machine does great ladies and
gentlemen you will be seeing the Tim
Dillon movie next summer yeah well
that's that we've loved that that is
almost guaranteed well if Comics do well
it helps other Comics right that's the
thing people [__] up on yes it's like
you get jealous of other Comics no dude
when Comics do great it helps you it
just helps you no one looks uh no one
looks at Joe Coy blowing the [__] up
right I mean and I'll tell you right now
I'm Different maybe I'm Different I
remember one time Joe Coy had a video
and because I would [__] around with Joe
and Tom yeah and bust balls on Instagram
and he had a video of a tour bus inside
an arena and he was like yo what's up
bird I just got done my show and all I
thought was
I I wanted my tour bus in an arena yeah
how awesome is that how awesome is that
right turns out it happens when there's
tornadoes but right it's not you don't
want it to happen you normally you just
want to tell me it means there's a
problem
[Laughter]
but like you want Comics to do good you
want Comics to blow up and and Joe is
the one that put that out there of like
help everyone they just help you right
but help them selflessly like I never I
never
I've never needed wanted anything from
anyone I just want to watch people blow
up when Tom blew up dude I had a moment
I've talked about this ad nauseam but I
remember I have a moment when I realized
Tom was
way more successful than I was and we
were just friends and we didn't have a
podcast together
it was during they used to do a thing
called Oddball
um yeah I remember the Oddball I got I
was on Comedy festivals they booked me
for 10.
or 12. and then they just kicked me off
because they were like yeah
and I was like I called Tom I was like
oh that sucks and he goes you're losing
out a lot of money I was like oh it's
two thousand dollars a week and then I
had to play for my travel in my hotel
and he goes you're how much did you get
paid I was like 2 000 a weekend
he was like oh I said wait what are you
getting paid he goes and he was like I
don't want to tell you because I don't
know if we can be friends if you hear it
right and I was like I had to make a
moment where I was like okay are you
cool with
finding out exactly where you are in
this business right because that's a
moment and I literally I was like I put
my arms on my knees like my arms on my
knees like squatted like sitting in my
desk and I had the phone sitting on my
desk and I thought about it and I was
like what's the number gonna be that I'm
cool with it I go 10 grand a weekend
right and we're in a weekend I'm like
that's fine maybe 20 grand a weekend and
he goes I'm getting paid 20 grand and I
went okay He Goes a show and I went what
right and I was like [__] that's
way bigger than I but I was like I'm
happy for him it was good it was good
for you to know that that was out there
yeah I'm happy I want to see everyone
succeed I want to learn from them like I
watch what Tom's doing with ymh and it's
really [__] inspiring you look at
what Joe's doing when Joe's Joe's been
the model that everyone builds after and
then you just try to do your own things
like I've only tried to do fully loaded
only because I had this thorn in my side
about getting kicked off funny or die
right and I was like I wanted I was the
guy that if I got to do that Festival I
would have had the best time out of any
comic that did it right I wouldn't have
stressed I would have just why did they
kick you off kind of [__] I mean
honestly for real now that I book a
festival because I wasn't gonna draw
names right and they could save money on
me I wasn't gonna bring anyone to the
show it was a favor they were doing I
wasn't bringing anyone to the show you
don't think that when you're young you
take it personally it wasn't personal
they just were like they were like yeah
let's save two grand a week and let's
let's see if we can get someone a little
bigger right throw that money towards
someone else so you you Direction you're
heading in now you're saying
everything's in-house yeah that's why I
think everything's moving and I look at
what you've got yeah this is the
direction yeah this is the direction
yeah but I I want
um be smart don't start kick the habit
put it out before it puts you out All
Phases we've heard a hundred times and
yet still continue to have bad habits
our sponsor fume is on a mission to
accelerate Humanity's breakup from the
bad habits to consume far too many of us
fume is a natural diffusive device that
uses plants and Behavioral Science to
help you trade out your negative habit
for a positive one fume is not a vape
it's a non-electronic device designed to
transform your negative habits
instead of PODS filled with potentially
harmful chemicals like a vape fume uses
cores infused with plants like
peppermint and cinnamon for delicious
natural flavors with an adjustable
airflow dial and a magnetic end cap your
fingers will always have something
to do
I like the look and the feel of it
I've had a personal experience with this
and I I will tell you that I use it and
I my friends have used it and they have
become better people
and their habits have gone away and they
now have good habits I have a friend
I'm not even gonna tell you what he used
to do
but he was in jail for many years
because he was very sick
and he did a lot of horrible things to a
lot of people
and many people refused to even admit
that they know him because he
you know he
I don't even want it's not even
important to like get in he was
accountable
he was accountable
but he was he didn't murder people but
he would eat he would find dead people
and eat them I'm not going to go into it
I'm just saying that's why he's not
still in jail he didn't murder
he got out of jail and he started uh
with fume
and because it has the shape with the
you know with the it goes with the hands
and the thing and the adjustable airflow
what happened to him was he stopped
eating people and he started using uh
film
the easiest way to stop a bad habit is
to switch to a positive one and fume is
designed to do just that it's fume's
goal to make switching easy even
enjoyable go to trifum.com use code Tim
that's try t-r-y fume fum.com and use
code Tim to save an additional 10 off on
your order today but now is there more
to be done in-house for example yeah is
it more content outside of podcasts oh I
think it's this is the thing right we
watched Louie make a movie we watched
you know we've watched a lot of stuff
happening now at one point it was very
difficult to do shows like this because
the technology wasn't there yet yeah uh
the platforms weren't there yet it's
still very hard to make a movie on your
own you still got to partner up with a
studio you still have you know in five
or ten years is that the same thing or
are people making [__] movies the way
that Studios made them okay so this is
my okay this is I'm gonna try to give
you an analogy for the way I look at
business
I don't
I I may be the shark at times
right but I'm comfortable being the
Amora also now explain what the Amora is
it's the [__] little sucker fish that
holds onto the shark and just takes a
ride interesting so like I want my
business to be all the amoras that are
on me all the time I want that to be my
business right so and so like let's say
for this is ideally this is how I would
have done it for the machine but I
wasn't set up to do that right I would
have signed a deal with legendary and I
would have said I would like to be in
control of my marketing I would like to
be in control of my social of all the
social media all the BTS I want to be in
control of all this all the outside
businesses that go along with making a
movie that that are representing me as
well I want to be in control of those
and I would like that money I would like
that I would like that coming to me so
when I build a media company I'm looking
at say I do a TV show again I'm looking
at all the outside [__] that they sh
that they'll Farm out PR social media
BTS all that [__] I want it coming to me
and so I want that I would like to do
that and I do it very well right and so
I already know I do it very well and
I've shown that I've done it very well
like the marketing for the machine not
to toot my own horn but I I got in front
of a movie that was sitting on the shelf
and got it off the shelf I got it off
the shelf I went and I leaked the
trailer on Rogan why was it on the Shelf
that's all the [__] [__] going with
the [__] Putin right everyone's
scared I mean like I shouldn't say this
because I know I mean I know that people
even now people will be like you know
but but everyone was nervous that maybe
received negatively I said it's not
about that it's a good [__] movie
it's a funny movie it's a funny it's a
[__] action comedy that has nothing
to do yeah it's not called Bert
Kreischer invades the Ukraine
it's the [__] movie about a story
you've been telling on stage forever but
people were like cats when that when all
that [__] happened down I remember
people going
so are you going to be able to tell the
machine on stage again and I was like
I'm fine yeah I don't think my fans now
then no one cares we're all a little
sick of this by the way yeah wrap the
[__] up we've had enough and so and so I
got that off the shelf they wanted to do
the announce I said let me do it I did
the announce
uh this went viral I said let me take
control of getting they gave me the
trailer I said let me take control of
getting that spread out yeah we had uh I
mean I shouldn't say numbers but we had
an a resounding effect with that trailer
within 24 hours same thing with Razzle
Dazzle I did Razzle Dazzle I took
control of all the BTS I took control of
all the marketing I took control of
everything BTS explained what BTS so I
have a film crew that comes with me and
shoots everything and then in that
process we shot the announced the
trailer and we did all the editing we
did all that and then so that's the
business I want to be in is like it's
like just covering my business I don't
need to be the studio I don't need to be
the director I want everyone around me
that's the best but when it comes to
like the little [__] jobs around me
I want I want to be running all those
yeah and that's and I think I think
there's people that are even better than
me that can do even more than that but
that's where I know I'm good at I know
I'm good at selling me to people that
like me right that's it I mean it's like
I do it with stand up I you know I
remember when I got into
when I got when I got the first Netflix
special I was very proud that I got
myself there yeah because you know you
got to get yourself there like you get
yourself there that's I know a lot of
people may
may see that differently when they look
at us but like you you got yourself a
special on Netflix no one got you a
special on Netflix right you did by your
stand up yeah you're waking up every day
and busting your [__] ass right you
got and that's something to be proud of
yeah yeah and so and and so I remember
getting secret time and I was so proud
of myself I was like I got myself here I
remember I think in the meeting this is
gonna sound horrible you know when you
say something that's just comes out
wrong yes
I was at Netflix yeah and they're
congratulating me on my special
and I I don't know why I said it but I
was like I got myself here
and everyone's like okay I was like no
no no no like no like I wasn't gifted
this like I earned this and it was like
a moment it was good that you no it's a
completely insane moment it's an insane
moment it's wildly inappropriate
punching me going nothing thank you well
you know what it was I made mortgage I
made a lot of money in mortgages one
month and my and I was like walking
around like I was the [__] and then my
old boss said hey he called me into the
office and I remember I was so
embarrassed he goes hey man act like
you've been here before Oh I am not that
guy God yeah I am not that guy it's my
first time and I'm letting you know it's
a surprise party that you've thrown for
yourself yes all the time all the time
dude I'm I've consistently I
consistently am I am I've had a friend
growing up the same as wicho he's from
Peru yeah originally and uh
I'm sorry if you're hearing this but
like he his his English was great he
would mispronounce words and sometimes
he wouldn't know what a word like he'd
say Rottweiler right and you're like
it's Rottweiler and you go but wiser and
you know it's Budweiser right and then
you say a word like uh
omnipotent any good what does that mean
and like where everyone else would just
go like I don't I don't know what it
means but I'm not gonna say anything he
had no problem saying I don't know what
that means tell me what that means
and I I enjoyed that about him because I
got to learn what the word meant too
because I didn't know what it meant and
so I I took from that like it's okay to
be a [__] country rube every step of
the way and let people know this is
[__] this is like I've never done
this before like I'm terrified I'm
nervous I'm scared this is fun like I am
[__] I am I'm the guy in the end zone
I'm the guy in the end zone that didn't
even score and I'm dancing your tour
schedule is so intense you're all over
the world really I mean you you've done
it's a lot of America have you gone
overseas I know you have
um what is is this sustainable Forever
My Life yes oh interesting no no no no
no no no no no no no I'm I I look at
your schedule and I I go on the road a
lot and I look at your schedule and I go
this is really amazing it's it's an
amazing commitment you've built
something that's wild
but I also go wow this is a you know
this is a pace that is incredibly you
know demanding well I think also there's
two things that go in with that number
one I was also and I've said this ad
nauseam but like I was also
when I met you I was not successful you
were less you were still successful in
my eyes when I met you I remember you
were doing six shows at the DC Improv
and you would sold them all out and I
was like in the little room yeah and I
had come to talk to you and you were
really really nice and kind and you were
telling me about the difference how was
selling out like there he goes you go
they're selling out they're selling out
pre-sale they're selling out netting
shows there's 30 tickets right do you
talk to me about that whole thing and
then you go to theaters after this and
you would tell me about all this stuff
but I remember you were still the one of
the biggest Club acts in the country but
you hadn't broken to the next level I
hadn't broken yeah I definitely hadn't
broken and so but there was a period too
where I was like I got where I got fired
from Travel Channel and I was right and
I was just like my podcast didn't have
money coming in and I was just like what
the [__] am I gonna do with myself and I
remember being at the store and and a
couple Comics that were more arguably
more successful than me one of them that
one of the most definitely
just leaving me mid-conversation for
someone more famous and I was like I was
like wow that's where I am and this
conversation with Tom so I think because
I got to experience that I look at this
going like make hay while the sun shines
I had someone tell me that the other day
uh one time this comic said you know it
doesn't go away you don't have to do it
all in one bite and I was like oh it
goes away it goes away for everybody it
goes worse everybody of course and it's
gonna go away for me look you look at
like you and I think you want it to go
away I think you need it to go and yeah
and that's what that makes you enjoy it
but I don't think I can keep this pace
up like this pace is insane I thought I
had a couple weeks off before I go to
Australia I don't I have three days off
and I was like [__] and so for me I just
would love to
I mean look I'll do it I'll do it until
the wheels come off right I mean I guess
yeah it's like what's the other option
what should I get into a TV show
no I don't know no meaning like should I
start watching secession like well it is
well number one it's a good show I
wouldn't I wouldn't uh replace working
with just watching a TV show yeah that
was yeah because that's the option do
you ever think do you ever think well
because you've done the movie now yeah
and you you've toured so much do you
ever
think of is there anything else you want
to be really good at do you ever look at
something and go [__]
I want to master some other
discipline whether it's related to this
business not in the business see what's
interesting about Rogan is he's got his
fighting right yeah he's got his martial
arts like he does that he's in there he
does Muay Thai he does jiu jitsu
whatever I'm gonna open a glass of roses
okay please
and what he does is that is so essential
to like who he is as a human being
because obviously he's got comedy he's
got work he's got a family but he's also
got this other thing and I always wonder
like is there another thing that do do
we miss out on not having that not that
it has to be fighting like do we miss
out on not having that other discipline
that
that some that he has
no I mean like maybe yeah I mean I like
like I'm not gonna start
jujitsu yeah but I'm just saying like
should mine be tennis
should mine be like
something where I'm like oh I've got the
people I do this with yeah we play
tennis we we we we keep score we we care
like I'm like what else is there in life
I don't know I don't know like what
what do people do people golf sure you
know people golf then you gotta check
back I know
I never checked back that's a Bert
Chrysler rule you can buy what you need
when you get there yeah [__] yeah I
never check bags
um I've thrown out so much bought [__]
where I go I just needed it and then I
go you make a good point because
sometimes I look at your schedule I'm
like that's crazy he's doing that but
then you're like what is the other like
the other day I was in the The Comedy
Store in the green room and like my
godson stops in he's Chinese he's two
and they threw him out because he's not
not allowed to be in the green room
because like some nonsense [__] rule
you know what I mean now they're
policing The Green Room over there great
after years of Guantanamo torture
supposedly people are getting but the
point is my little godsend instructor
and I'm going what am I supposed to do
be here every night like I like it but
what am I supposed like yes Birds on the
road like a demon bat out of hell I mean
he's got more miles on him than like the
pagans motorcycle gang I mean you are
out there but it makes sense because
after a certain point what are you going
to do you can't do spots no you can't
just show up to a place and do spots you
know what I mean there is a certain
there is a progression where I feel like
you are doing the right thing of like
you outgrow certain things in comedy
where it's like
some of it's fun and then you go you
know what if I can't create my own world
this whole thing's about creating our
own world oh yeah and that's what you've
been able to do on the road you have
your friends the people you like the you
know you have created your own world and
then when you're living in these other
worlds they're like the baby's gotta go
and this and that and you go hey man oh
I have a I have a real problem with uh
with rules Bluetooth do I even need to
describe this but I will it's a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as Viagra Cialis and
Levitra but in a chewable tablets at a
fraction of the cost you could take them
anytime day or night so you can plan
ahead or be ready whenever an
opportunity arises the process is simple
sign up at bluetooth.com consult with
one of their licensed medical providers
and once you're approved you'll receive
your prescription within days the best
part it's all done online to no visits
to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations no waiting in line at the
pharmacy Bluetooth tablets are made in
the USA and prepared and shipped direct
you door in a discreet package guys
remember the days when you're always
ready to go don't be that guy that says
I missed out or I don't need it
go to Bluetooth it helps the penis get
hard Bluetooth wants to help you have
better sex discover your options
bluetooth.com chew it and do it and
we've got a special deal for our
listeners try Bluetooth free
when you use our promo code TD at
checkout
just pay five dollars shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code TD to receive
your first month free visit
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information we thank
Bluetooth for sponsoring the podcast
yeah I have a real problem like I set
myself up into into a world where I got
to define the rules right it's like
little things little things like when uh
when people are like like last night uh
I I got a hotel room we were in wherever
we were and I got a hotel room for the
afternoon I said I'm gonna sleep I have
a busy week this day I'm gonna I'm not
gonna [__] around I'm not gonna work out
I'm not gonna do play disc golf I'm
gonna sleep today in the hotel room and
then I'll go to the show and my
assistant came in and he's like show
starts it at seven we should be out of
here by like 6 30 and I went no
and he goes what I said when do I go on
I'm not going on it's seven I'm not I
don't need to be there early don't right
like I like little things like that I go
it starts when I show up and right and
if it and and so just so we're clear I'm
not gonna get there and and like I'm
like that with the airport like I just
I'm so [__] bad I agree with you I
have clear I go right before the fly
yeah I like to get there I don't wait I
don't wait for one person on my team if
you're not ready I'm walking I'm going
with you and sadly I do that with my
family yeah with my girls I go hey sorry
girls you're [__] around you guys
everyone it's you're on the plane we
[__] Leanne one time I go i s we're
we're in line at security and she goes I
don't I go let's go through clearance
she goes I don't have clear I go okay
well you wait here I'm gonna go in she
goes well why aren't you waiting with me
I go because I'm not because I'm not an
idiot right I didn't set my life up to
to be an idiot right you set it up to do
idiot things right like not have clear
not have clear I'm going in clear and
there's stupid [__] yeah so and then
she goes just wait I'm your wife you
wait with me and then I can hear people
commenting what the [__] wrong with
you Bert no they don't know they don't
get it so I wait with her and clear
it's so demoralized I waited with her
and [__] just in regular [__]
Whatchamacallit disgusting and then we
get up and she goes oh I got that white
box thing and I go that that's clear she
goes oh I got that I went oh
oh my God I know you're not supposed to
hit women no but sometimes but like that
would have been a time no that would
have been that would have been
definitely I was so angry because I got
bad I didn't know what that's why you
why why didn't you tell me this white
box thing right oh my [__] god Leanna
versus said to slow it down yeah yes you
said it today yeah she called me today
and I and I and said oh I don't know
wherever I was on the plane or whatever
where the [__] I was
she goes uh I'm gonna call Tim and
cancel today you need to you need to
rest and I went hold on I love Leanne I
would have totally been okay with that
no I said but I I do like that you're
here out of all the things I'm doing
today this is the one thing I would like
right aggressively fine cancel the other
[__] yes this is the one thing I like
I'm getting to drive into Beverly Hills
yeah I get to see [__] L.A I get to
feel like I live here I went over the
hill right this is the [__] thing I
got a bottle of Rose this is where my
tracksuit I have a bottle of Rose in a
in a beautiful okay it's like you know
my father had one of these bags but he
was a wine salesman but I like that you
have it and it's not your business this
is your personal and your enjoyment but
this is what I like well just me and you
gossiping out there oh this is the
[__] thing I live for it's just so
it's fun to hang out with someone and
just compliment to other comedians yeah
yeah just talk great about how few
specials are being released these days
how many specials I think it's 150 to
date too many from January to March
that's too many 150. what is comedy in
five or ten years is it anything we
recognize no it's not going to be
something we recognize Albert tell us
what it is because
I feel like you kind of know or do you
do you have an idea well I think our
manager is still going to be around no
they're gone wow
managers are did you hear that managers
you're done I think managers the third
biggest comedian or fourth third fourth
or fourth fourth biggest comedian
telling you you're done you are done I
think I mean I think I think what
happens is everything's in-house once
again Doug Stanhope is the Prototype
that's right Doug Stanhope did it right
that's right and I remember telling my
manager I want what Doug has and she was
like maybe maybe that's not exactly what
you want right like you don't live in
Bisbee in a compound and but but Doug
has everything talked about him he has
his own bartender he brings everybody in
everybody's under the umbrella of what
he wants to do and what his vision is
but you got to be willing to [__]
work non-stop that's the other thing I
think that people don't realize you're
not working less now you're working more
way more you're actually working way
more than you would have when you could
rely on Comedy Central or whatever where
you would just show up now you are
working you're hiring people you're
interviewing people you're figuring out
dynamic you're being a man it's weird
it's different I went to stabby's house
the other day yeah and he had five
people in there one dude and it's his
house podcast Studio an editing Bay yeah
he said he woke up the other day and
there's a guy on the couch that he
didn't know right and but that he stobby
works like that all the time that's the
norm if you're not willing to work all
the time then you may get passed by
that's right look at Schultz Schultz is
all the trusting his you go into his
place and everything's in house with
Schultz yeah his best friend agent
manager right I mean he does everything
and then he's got a great team of people
around him that are all willing to to
work 24 hours is there a danger let me
ask the danger though cause I always
like to look at the other side of things
okay is there a danger that when
everybody's working so hard and I I
understand this and I'm doing it we're
all running around are we not living no
this is living this is living this is
living this is living what about what
well like having interactions with
people that weren't monetized have you
ever talked have you ever talked to a
[__] regular person I know Jesus
Christ go to drop off at my kid's school
one time yeah okay and then just watch
those conversations sometimes I wonder
about the the great material that we
kind of pull from life you you're gonna
get it like I mean like here's the deal
you're gonna live a regular life that's
right you're gonna live a regular life I
have regular friends we have a group of
friends called the campers we all hang
out and talk and we do [__] we go on
vacation together that's gonna [__]
happen of course you can't not that's
not not gonna happen but like I don't
want to sit out there and like I don't
like I don't need to I don't need to
like immerse myself in a pickleball
League no I don't I'm not gonna do uh
adult softball right like I'm not like
none of that [__] matters to me agreed
like I I mean I I would I I guess I get
drawn to my interests
which I like I like a good conversation
at an airport bar yes I like a good
conversation at a dive bar I like going
and seeing houses I'm not gonna buy I
love that there's nothing better than
that oh there's so much it helps the
realtor because it trains can we go
let's go house anytime you want but I
immediately immediately go let's
monitors
yeah why don't we film it 100 open
houses I will do it tomorrow I will do
it anytime you want do you know what my
favorite thing to do is yeah uh I like
to profile the people whose house we're
looking at oh and see yeah I mean well
that's my whole my thing was like fake
business where I would call Realtors and
I would get into actual negotiations
about a property and I would say I would
be a fake realtor and I would call them
up and I'd go listen my clients are
deadly serious they live in the United
Arab Emirates but here's you know here's
a couple of things that we need to get
we need to you know and what what
happens is it's immediately real
business for the realtor but it's fake
business for me and it's real business
for them but it's fake business for me
because the clients don't really exist
they don't know it's a big business
ninety percent of what you do in sales
is fake business it's not real until
they sign the thing which very few
people do yeah so even though it's fake
business it's real business for them
yeah so it trains them it keeps them
going you're just fun for me I represent
a lot of very Discerning clients in the
Los Angeles area none of them exist
none of them exist but they are high-end
they're very Discerning they want Malibu
on the water they want Beverly Flats if
they want prime prime and they're I
represent hedge funds Real Estate
Investment Trust I represent massive
guys that are from Greenwich Connecticut
oh my God I represent them and I call
these Realtors oh they waste all of
their time the ones you see on TV and
and and and they just go along with it
because they have they're vapid and
there's nothing inside of them except
they just wanna someone to sign this
goddamn paper and it's the best I like
wasting the time of people and it's
really it's good it's a great thing for
both of us because sometimes I have time
and I'm in traffic and I just pull them
up and I go listen how are you I go how
are you listening I have a client that's
very excited about this property it
seems priced a little higher relative to
some of the comps in the area and I just
wanted to know are there details about
the house that would justify that I'll
wait and then they're like well
absolutely I'm glad you asked so the
owner actually yeah and I do it all the
time and I love it it's I have no
respect for the real estate profession
and and I do but I don't yeah so what
it's fun it's great to waste your time
I've brought them up to um like the
offers coming in and you can tell these
people can tell
and I only do it to high-end people I
wouldn't hurt the small and medium
people that need the money I do it to
high-end people and I'm like the offer
is coming in this afternoon and they'll
call me back they're like what happened
with that offer I'm like oh my God
you'll never believe what you'll never
believe what hat they invaded to Ukraine
so to me I would love I think Tim Dillon
Burke Chrysler I love real estate it's
fascinating to me Realtors are very dumb
and they make a lot of money and that's
those are my favorite types of people
that's the American dream to not be
educated to just kind of be like Fly by
Night and to somehow a massive Fortune
talking about tile the American dream oh
my God so these are my these are things
I like these are passions I have like
and you're right it's like we shouldn't
feel guilty that we don't do Jujitsu or
whatever because we have things that
we're also we would have I mean first of
all here's the thing is like we would
have been that guy already that's a good
point like I mean Joe was not a comic
who discovered Jujitsu no he was doing
that when he was in the martial arts
like I got right he was in a martial
arts like I can play golf I'm really
good at golf but like I'm not the guy
that wants to go I mean I don't like I
like playing golf every now and then but
I want to do it if like I want to do it
once in a while right um I I can play
tennis too and I used to do it in the
mornings but you want to do the garden
what's that Madison Square Garden do I
yeah is this part of is this I would
imagine it's kind of a is it a pinnacle
or not it's not my it's not my white
whale okay I mean it would be cool be
really cool yeah but it's definitely not
I mean like what is the white whale if
there is a white whale I don't know I
think I I think I got it you I think
you've got many of them I think well I
mean Red Rocks is a big deal for me
massive and uh such a cool place it's so
cool and then Red Rocks are cool a
cruise was a big deal for me right
um uh the bar I did the Boston Garden
which I didn't wasn't on my list well no
my radar right it was one of the coolest
things I've ever done yeah in my career
and then the Emily center in Tampa we
sold I sold that out and that was like I
don't forget what the number was but it
was like it was [__] sold to the
ceiling and my parents were there they
were in a box with yeah like a bunch of
sports guys where they was like a big
[__] deal I don't think I have I
don't think I have like uh I don't
really have I mean doing Madison Square
Garden would be massive it would be
[__] amazing yeah
um I think it would be great I think
it'd be great
but it's like it's like at this point I
I it would be awesome I don't you don't
want to negate it yeah
but uh I've just done more than I ever
thought I do so I don't it's hard to
like what advice do you give to guys
that are like opening for you on the
road do you what do you tell them Don't
Stop opening for me right yeah because
that's the worst thing you can do that's
because we were talking about the thing
before you don't you don't ever want to
be viewed as someone's opener so you say
to them Stop opening for me one guy I
just thought I was like I like him way
too much and I just had to I I had to be
like he needs to do his own thing right
because right now people are seeing him
as is my guy right which is the worst
thing that can happen that's right
because then you go to clubs and people
don't I mean you don't know this but
people don't respect you right they go
oh he's only he's only dot dot because
dot dot dot right and so um there's a
couple guys that I had to do that too
because I like him so much and and and
they're fun and they're fun they're fun
they're the I mean the best and they're
great Comics but it's just unfortunately
you do have to tell them like get away
from me yeah like when I started working
with JoJo asked me to open for him a
couple times and I was like I was like I
don't wanna I like I want to be your
friend right I don't want to depend on
you for money and I don't like I don't
want to be like look at your schedule
ever and go like oh [__] he's doing this
why maybe I should text him and say that
see that's that's absolutely I've opened
for only a few people a handful of times
you were one of them yeah but you but
you open for me once yes and then you
were like and then I hit you up again
you're like nah yeah and then and then I
mean and I would argue yeah in this in
this algorithm I just created yeah look
where you are well yeah yeah but you're
not you've never been someone's opener
never you've never been here
I did that Sandy sad gig with you in San
Antonio and then I did that Theater now
you're in an arena but I did that
theater a couple years later because I
was like I just want to get to these
places on my own yeah and I was able to
do like the Chicago theater on my own
and the Masonic and all these amazing
rooms the beacon what you've done is
insane I mean it's insane I mean you
don't understand it's like it's it's so
impressive to see mostly not just the
venues you're playing but from my side
I'm a little more of the business side
how quickly you sell them out like
that's what's impressive well you know I
think that like and who you're touring
with like yeah like I mean same Talent
Sam Talent is one of the greatest comics
in the country he's one of my favorite
people he wrote a book about stand-up
that's brilliant it's brilliant you know
what I mean running the light if you
haven't bought it you know you will and
he's gonna do Rogan soon my last opener
Marcelo Hernandez is now on Saturday
Night Live and like the Breakout cast
member so like the the people that I've
been lucky enough to kind of I look at
people that are working hard that are
good or whatever and um you've got to
have that you've got to have that energy
for yourself guys go get expressvpn
don't be stupid this new thing that came
out they're trying to ban vpns obviously
they're doing you know the government's
trying to ban them it means they're good
and they're helping you
going online without expressvpn is like
leaving your kids in the with the
nearest stranger while using the
restroom well what's wrong with that who
writes these
anyway the point is expressvpn is
basically security okay it's not letting
people steal your data whether it be the
government or private corporations uh
it's very important it creates a secure
encrypted tunnel between your device and
the internet so that hackers cannot
steal your data hackers can make some
serious cash selling personal
information on the dark web but
expressvpn has made it easier than ever
to keep your information safe literally
everyone I know has a VPN right now
everybody
I mean if you don't have one it's like
crazy you're like leaving your house
naked secure your online data today go
to
expressvpn.com Tim Dylan you get three
months free no games no gimmicks easy 90
days for free
expressvpn.com Tim Dillon get three
extra months 90 days absolutely free
I'm telling you there's no reason not to
do it no reason not to do it this
prevents people hackers
corporations
these other websites social media
companies harvesting your data selling
your data putting you on a list all of
these things are prevented when you use
expressvpn it is so important
um you know when you're connecting to an
unencrypted Network in cafes hotels
airports any network that's not your own
your online data is never secured so you
have no idea any hacker on that Network
you can sit in an airport and just
[__] get people's info okay so the
reality is expressvpn is the best VPN
it's one that everyone uses and if
you're a fan of the show it makes sense
you get 90 days free three months
expressvpn.com Tim Dylan and I think
that like listen and you did I've been
lucky enough to like Joe Rogan people
like you people like Joe have been
really good to me you've shared your
audience with me in different ways
you've allowed me to come on your shows
and be funny and you know I was able to
I didn't know what podcast guessing was
when I started I was able to get into it
I was good at it I loved radio as a kid
I listened to everybody I love all kinds
of weird radio from psychologists to
preachers I love to [__] political I
loved you know when I would drive around
with my grandmother in Long Island when
I was an actor and they had me in like
singing class and dance class and we
would listen to Rush Limbaugh this is
how gay Republicans are created this is
the lab the laboratory is a Ford Taurus
on Long Island being driven a dance
class but on the way listening to a lot
of crime statistics and I uh just fell
in love with the idea of radio and and
and podcasting I just liked it and we
talked to people twice a week every week
and those people have been nice to
support us in a myriad of ways but one
of them is coming out to see me do stand
up and you know having a great time
doing that so I I've been lucky enough
that there's a platform to to you know
that I saw you guys when I got out to LA
I moved I looked at all you guys and I
went that's what I want yeah but you
you've got the you've got there's a gene
that you have or you don't have in
comedy yeah and that Gene is and I I
would argue maybe I I'm on the fence
with it I guess I'm not anymore Tom has
it yeah you and Tom have the same gene
where you do not mind working under
someone and figuring things out yeah but
within a matter of seconds you're
leapfrogging over them well I always I
always like to learn from people I like
to learn I like to learn I always
learned I was always paying attention to
what they did that I didn't like yeah
and then I go oh don't do that like
that's the easiest way for me to
to
uh to get better was to see what I
didn't like what people did when I came
to La it was an interesting time because
I was exposed to not only comedians but
I was sitting down with people like
Logan Paul I was doing his podcast I
just did his podcast the other day
you're amazing you and Logan Paul Paul
was so much fun yeah because you know
then and I got to be honest with you
that was the thing that transitioned
Logan Paul for me where I went okay I'm
gonna I'm gonna start paying attention
to him cool dude and he likes comedy and
and so being exposed to like that world
and people like the nelk kids and Hannah
Mojo all these people that had built
careers on the internet that weren't
necessarily comedians but they were
personalities and you take a little bit
for what they do I mean you did that no
one else was doing that you know that
right yeah no I almost was [__] with
Logan Paul interesting and I remember
you came and you went on Rogan and you
said if I had all the money in the world
I'd invest in him being president I
would and I went and you but you
understand that like you'll never get
this the way I get it right but like we
were so set in our ways as Comics yeah
that we looked at the internet guys as
like whatever right and you looked at
them seriously and you were like Logan
Paul has a huge following and he's
putting out content and he's a fun guy
and he's nice and I literally now look
at it Sebastian fluffy Theo me Rob
Dyrdek everyone does Logan Paul's
podcast everybody and and listen when I
did it I I was like I didn't know him
but then I met him and I was like this
guy's actually pretty cool I saw him uh
you know talking about comedy he liked
comedy like so to me it's like listen I
think there's things you can learn from
all kinds of different people and I
think Comics get very stuck in whatever
mode they're in in the model of doing
something and I got Flack some of my
fans were like that's [__] up you
would talk to these guys I had Jake Paul
on my podcast at the Bitcoin convention
Miami with the Winklevoss twins these
are hilarious moments in my life where
I'm sitting on a stage remember I
started comedy in a tattoo parlor coffee
shop in Long Island called wild child
spelled with a Y like wild and I'm
sitting at the Bitcoin Convention in
Miami where [__] the head of Twitter
Jack Dorsey just got off the stage then
I'm getting on the stage and I'm
interviewing the wigglevoss Twins and
Jake Paul and it's hilarious [__]
awesome these are insane lives and to me
that was the fun of it so the fun of it
to me is like not being bored and
creating insane things that are fun
whereas it's like I'll talk to anyone I
just messaged David Hogg the kid from
Portland and I'm like I'd love to just
talk to you on my show I have no agenda
he hasn't gotten back to me that's fine
maybe this will find its way to him but
I'll talk to anybody and and it's
because like I just want to have fun and
I want to do cool [__] that I wouldn't
be doing if I was still a mortgage guy
but you're but your your Vibe has always
been
so authentically you I mean and and I
not to discredit what I said earlier
about like loving finding you or
whatever but like when I met you I just
was like
you ever meet someone and you're like
I'm not done getting to know that person
yeah yeah if I want to meet is how I
guess you ultimately fall in love with
people but it's also how you make
friends where you go like like when I
met Tom I remember going like how is he
so confident right like I remember being
like how does he believe in himself
right and and when I met Joe I was I was
like
how is he so curious I mean like if that
the one word I say about Joe he is the
most he wants to know [__] that
I go I'm not more Curious when I met you
I was like I was like I'm not done
talking to him yeah and I was like I
gotta I want to get to know him and I
think I think that's the fun in this
business is like
just
like there are people that look at it in
in micro bites and they're like how do I
get this how do I get that how do I get
this as opposed to looking at the bigger
picture going like look at that how do I
shoot in that direction yeah how do I
get and how do I land over here and and
I I think we were cutting our nose off
despite our face with all the
interesting people that we could have
met I think Joe is a huge part of that
but you I mean
I can just say about the Logan Paul [__]
I would never have [__] with Logan
Paul well I appreciate it I I think that
like they're these worlds that we're all
in now are no longer as isolated as they
were yeah everybody is in the same place
everybody is making stuff everybody is
has an audience everything is this is
how I'd run your business yeah this is
what I do if I could be you yes I'd love
to be you
wow you're so much better than I am
that's not true I didn't know you really
are like because I know how good I am
like trust me I would love to be you so
what should I do uh I I would have how
many employees do you have right now
we have
one to two we have about two okay we
have very lean operations we're gonna
have to scale up I know I know we're
gonna we should get more people you need
six eight you need you need a personal
assistant that's dealing just with your
touring yes and then you I agree and
then you need I would say I would bring
someone on to help you focus on your
movie stuff yes uh and then
and then I would start there and then
when I when I signed a movie deal I
would say I would I would if I were you
I would take control of everything they
have right I mean you're you're
I mean I I I your trajectory of your
career is going to be astronomical I
think
I would have all those people in place
for when it happens it's very nice of
you to say um and here's the problem is
that you're I know the problem is that
right now with small overhead and a big
income you don't have to worry about
money
no that's the problem but the other
thing is like do you have a manager no I
would get I would hire someone to be
your manager really I would really yeah
what about yours I would you can get
mine does she not like me does she like
me no she loves you she loves you she
loves you I feel like me and her there's
weird similarity maybe in a sense she
loves you and she loves you I I don't I
can't talk too much about it of course
about her because like as I say I'm
getting Management's going away I'll
never stop working with her no of course
her insights her insights have been
golden for me on so many times when I
did uh the hot summer night store when I
I created the drive-in movie theater
tour yeah
um I backed out initially they booked me
like 12 dates and I backed out and I
said I'm out I don't want to do it
everyone was telling me don't do it and
I'm a regular guy I'm not like this
[__] guy that knows everything I just
I sometimes I'll have crazy ideas and
then I have people in place to put them
in place and then I backed out and she
goes don't back out do it and I said
what do you mean she goes I know you and
even if it sucks
you will create content out of it it'll
be worth the right the things let's
scale it down from 12 to 6 and just try
it see if you like it and if you don't
like it it's six things that you just
try and you have content from at least
you got out of the house over the
pandemic just try it and I went you're
right I'm gonna try it yeah and I did it
and I fell in love with it the very
first night and then I ended up doing 60
cities and but it but she is
the other thing about her her name is
Judy marmell we should tell her name yes
only because she is a gangster she has
the brain she's got some of the biggest
comics in the world she yeah she does
she has the brain that does not shut off
for your life right Judy
will
Judy's the first person that I we I did
the Impractical Jokers cruise and I
pulled her aside I said I want to do a
cruise
she's like what I said this is like my
white whale yeah that I was on that
cruise with you yeah and you loved it I
had more fun yeah than anyone on that
boat yeah I was saying to myself like a
bird's gonna do one of these and you
even said back then you said I need to
do a cruise I pulled her and Nick news
40 aside and I said I need to do a
cruise this I have to do this and we put
everything in MO she Judy literally
never forgot that thing and thought
about it Non-Stop and would send me
articles uh Kid Rock's Cruise uh the
[__] the WWE Cruise like she thought
about it not that's the thing that's a
gangster about her I wish I could I wish
I mean I'll tell her to say this out
loud I wish you'd get rid of all her
clients and just work with me right
that's the move right that's the move
you know but yeah like but yeah she
would [__]
she would you know she would crush it
for you but you don't you I mean like
you are so here's what here's what
you're you're making a good point there
is a lot I do put a lot on the people
that I work with in the sense that you
know it becomes uh I think hard to know
who you'll need coming up because
there's different like the movie side's
A Different World and like all those
things are different worlds and I don't
know in those worlds I don't know nearly
what I know like in this world so in
this world I know exactly what's needed
I know exactly in those other worlds
it's a lot of different requirements and
stuff like that but Eli I'm excited
about the Eli Roth I think like I'm
excited I always when I was growing up
wanted
I looked at these comedy movies and I I
always loved them I wanted to be in them
and then I always and I think over the
last few years ago we need more of them
and we need them now we need those types
of movies that are like early mid-2000s
comedy silly goofy movies that people
can just escape and relax and I think
we're missing that think about how big
comedy is right now it's huge I mean
tickets are amazing like it's as big as
it's been on the live side it feels like
oh it's it's never been here how many
comedians and I mean you've been in this
for a long time how many comedians are
theater Comics a lot
how many people are Arena continents a
lot unless they're in the Arena Comics
you Tom Joe
um Dave Chappelle Chris Rock Bill Burr
Louis CK if he wants to I know he's you
know whatever
um Chelsea Handler
um
uh you know there's there's others too I
mean there's there's Arena Arenas when
we were growing up it was dice right it
was dice then it was Dane yeah and then
it was like one person became an arena
comic and they were the biggest one in
the world now we're all doing them and
and by the way I mean I mean not to not
to but you're the Arena Comics are being
doing arena is very accessible these
days I believe I believe when you get
learn we learned how to take charge of
our own careers yeah and isolate our fan
bases and go like yo this is what I like
you like that yeah we're all on the same
page right come watch me do stand up
right back in the day it was like you
hoped you Omaha Funny Bone sent out a
mailer list yeah to get people at your
show no this is a whole new world it's a
world a look at Matt Rife who's killing
it that rice is a sweet kid it's awkward
because it's like we look so much alike
that people are always like who which
one is you yeah and yeah I get that a
lot with that's Trevor Wallace that's
very hard Trevor Wallace also yeah so
like all these people like this isn't
just you can go out now and make your
career what you want it to be there's
nobody really holding anybody back and
there's no Gatekeepers there's no
Gatekeepers so that energy has got to go
away like that energy of like any
bitterness or any resentment or any
anger that you have cannot be justified
or rational right now in this moment in
the world nope at you can be resentful
at the government you'd be resentful to
your parents I'm presentable both of
those but you cannot be resentful at
anyone in this business keeping you down
dude so many times listen I don't even
want to talk about this because it's a
personal situation
I was trying to buy
um
tickets I don't I'm gonna go into this
right now and because it's truly
something that's is real
my schizophrenic mother
we wanted
I'm trying to say how to do
we wanted to euthanize my mother at a
Taylor Swift concert
because it's about that time
and my mother isn't doesn't really even
she didn't really even know Taylor Swift
but we were going to explain to her to
you who Taylor Swift was and how cool it
was that we got tickets for her and and
we were going to euthanize her at the
Taylor Swift concert so that she could
enjoy a performance from Taylor Swift as
the FI and that would be the final thing
she would see on this Earth
um
and we couldn't do it it was very tough
so I mean the reality is buying tickets
to your favorite event shouldn't be that
stressful
game time is a fast and easy way to buy
tickets for all the sports music comedy
at theaters near you with some killer
deals on last minute tickets and their
best price guarantee you can stop
stressing over the tickets and start
getting hyped for the fun you'll have
I mean browse through game time app and
talk about upcoming events in your area
concerts playoff games everything forget
planning months in advance game time has
deals on tickets right up until the day
of the event get exclusive Flash Deals
on tickets for football basketball
baseball concerts comedy theaters and
more game time guarantee means you'll
always get the best price if you find
ticket to the same section in row for
last game time we'll credit you 110 for
the difference
get images of your seats right before
you buy you know exactly what to expect
when you arrive buy tickets in a matter
of seconds two Taps and you're set so
I'm telling you right now download the
game time app you won't regret this I've
downloaded it I'm using it download the
game time app create an account use the
code Tim for 20 off your first purchase
go do this
like going out and seeing [__] great
last minute ticket deals great date [__]
you're going on a date you go hey you
want to go see this you want to go to a
game or some people oh my God you got
tickets of course I did
download the Gametime app create an
account use the code Tim for 20 off your
first purchase terms apply again create
account redeem code Tim
for 20 off
this is perfect last minute tickets
lowest price guaranteed this is a great
thing you can go on this app the morning
of something and then surprise all your
buddies go we all have tickets tonight
how cool is that I'm telling you Game
Time download the app create an account
use the code temp for twenty dollars off
your first purchase no and I remember
when I was resentful you sure me too I
remember that so I remember when
somebody would get the Montreal Comedy
Festival and I wouldn't get it and I had
a great audition and I'd sit there and
I'd be outside New York comedy club or
whatever smoking a cigarette in a in New
York City and I'd be like [__]
but this is what it is I remember being
resentful for people that didn't know I
existed right they didn't know I existed
I like that and I would just be like I
hate you I hate these people for not
knowing and then I'd run into them and
I'd be like what's up and they'd be like
hi I've never met you before and I'm
like oh for real right but you didn't
get my submission tape yeah oh I was so
pathetic I would do submission tapes and
I had cool music in the front that I
thought the guy would like oh God I wish
I you had one of these oh my God it was
what kind of cool music This Heart Is On
Fire
I am so pathetic and then you would get
out there and you would go just do you
would just do jokes my stand-up was so
bad when I was yeah that's the other
thing I would say is like
I got really lucky it's it's uh this is
a big statement okay that could get me
in trouble no that's okay what's
happening right now with comedy
is what happened
is what is what happens to hot chicks in
comedy interesting
so hot chicks and comedy
they get scooped up the second they step
on the scene that's right if you're
beautiful you're in and you're pretty
good right even
pretty confident you're in you're you're
scooped up and you got spots you wanna
you wanna headline we'll take your
headline agents managers let's get you
in let's get you into theaters let's get
you into right like let's let's do this
for you that's right now there's some
exceptions to this rule
and I'll say Chelsea Handler's a big
exception she's beautiful and man when I
first saw her she was a gangster on
stage right but I will say that that is
the problem is that a pretty woman
sometimes allies is an exception but
they get scooped up and they get put in
positions that they're maybe not ready
for
um I got very lucky in that I was just a
dude who got to be good or mediocre for
a very long time and then I got pretty
good and then I got that hot chick
moment where they put they go you ready
for something and then you're like oh
I'm already good I know how to do this
I've been doing it for 22 years right
that's what's gonna happen with comics
comics are gonna they're gonna get
they're gonna get like a video that goes
big online yeah and they're and
everyone's gonna be like oh [__] we
gotta go see them and then they're not
gonna be ready it's the Last Comic
Standing probably purple Parable Parable
is where these guys could do five
minutes ten minutes and then you're like
holy [__] that's the guy and then they
blow it during an hour they blow up well
they can't they can't sustain so does
this does this comedy boom that we're in
right now does it end does it kind of is
it the result of we're out of the
pandemic and everything but do you see
it ever Contracting and going you know
kind of getting smaller it has to it
seems like it inevitably has to I was
saying this earlier it's gonna start
when the when the cool kids start hating
us
yeah when once they probably already do
I think they definitely know me they
don't know
some of them like me I think a little
but I feel like that's ending too yeah
there I mean once by the way I I
celebrate it I bring it I'm a fan of
[__] comedy that's the thing they
have to hate us dude when Nirvana told
Molly crudico [__] themselves that's the
thing that's right right when the first
comic that's like someone one of these
kids at the mothership is gonna smack me
in the face with brisket and then just
get on stage and replace me I mean
that's the thing is like
I mean it's a gangster [__] move and
not to like but the
that that's what makes art cool yeah for
sure is they got to be like yeah I don't
want to be a [__] Arena comic yeah
[__] you well that's what he also seem
like when we started when I started now
when you started but when I started
everybody had a PBR a beard New Balance
sneakers they were all in Brooklyn or
Echo Park yeah you couldn't get on TV
unless they loved you we were all doing
shows like Whiplash and meltdown it was
Melania Camal and Pete and all these
guys it was the outgrowth of the scene
in Brooklyn New York and in like Echo
Park and Silver Lake Los Angeles and
then I remember things started to change
that guy code came in and that started
to change because my code was the
[__] Canary remember God couldn't
grow good people oh they can sell
tickets and they're not hipsters
interesting maybe there's a whole Market
here that we're [__] ignoring oh and
so all of a sudden all these Gatekeepers
that for a year and I know some of them
uh you know these guys that used to
produce these really big shows and they
used to work at management companies
maybe some of them worked at Comedy
Central like they were the ones who were
curating comedy they lived in Brooklyn
all their friends were like we're going
to this room never clubs it was like a
room the Knitting Factory or a Hannibal
show or whatever Whiplash and then the
guy called Girl Code thing happened and
it's like oh my God so this is
underserved Market of essentially
regular people that are younger that
don't live in Brooklyn and don't want to
hear Arcane literary references it will
buy tickets and Guy Code launched a
bunch of these different people and that
was kind of the beginning of the change
of like then the club started to open up
and when some of these new Young
creative guys that are hanging out
downtown let's have them in let's have
them in and the seller and the stand in
New York and other clubs started
bringing in younger hipper comics and
then the old scene kind of dissipated oh
yeah and then it just kind of became and
the internet but I remember when we
started it looked nothing like it does
now so I only wonder and that was I
started 12 years ago so I only Wonder 10
12 years from now if it'll look anything
like it does it's so interesting I'm
gonna be [__]
65. you'll be out there I'll still be
hanging out oh you'll be I'll be hanging
out and I'll celebrate it I actually
think you'll still be doing massive
shows I would like to be I would like to
be I'd like to be like Ron White like
Ron White I think maybe not just
frequently but I think you'll be out
there
killing I just wonder what it'll be like
in tenure it might be interesting like
I'm wondering right now every comic goes
out the Oliver camera they're all
filming their stats they're all cutting
you know we weren't allowed to do that
no yeah they would tell you you can't
film in here right and you'll be like
all the time because like their idea of
filming was this big dude this kid that
was opening for me nice kid we get to
Rogan's Club I give him a guest spot on
a show I'm doing Rihanna's Papas and he
goes can I set up a cat I got Buddy
Buddy Buddy your first time in Joe
Rogan's new comedy club nobody knows who
the [__] you are you've been doing
comedy two and a half years but
immediately he's like well wait what's
in it for me where's my clip I want my
Mothership clip oh [__] but but that's
there that's the way it is now
that's the way it is
and I get it because he's like what am I
gonna do like you sit there and do 500
hours of a podcast you [__] [__]
I'm gonna do One Clip that's a [__]
dude that's a moment they all look at us
like dinosaurs they go who gives a [__]
your bird Chrysler sits in chicken one
you're gonna just [__] sit there and
you guys are gonna talk about whatever
they're basically like it's a minute
it's a great clip it's viral on Tick
Tock and then boom Off to the Races oh
and there's nothing wrong with that it's
the new way to do it you I I'm obsessed
with it I can't believe we isolated it
yeah
one day we're gonna be Motley Crew
That's it into the VMAs 100 going up to
Kurt Cobain going hey man I'm a big fan
and he's gonna go go [__] yourself right
oh that's gonna suck I hope but it's
gonna be beautiful because look at the
it's a nice Journey it's a nice Journey
it's a nice journey and look Motley Crue
came back they're doing big tours now
it'll all come it comes in waves yeah
it comes in waves what sucks what sucks
is one day Rogan won't have his podcast
can you imagine that no no no no no no
no don't you say that don't you say that
I have to do you know that one day
eventually there won't be a Joe Rogan
only and this flips me out because for
my life my career my everything I've
always I just know that it's going on I
know that he's sitting across a desk
from somebody I know if I want to listen
to it if I'm on a plane or whatever it's
gonna be there but one day I don't know
not anytime soon perhaps but like one
day it won't exist Larry King went until
the day he died that's true maybe maybe
Joe will do the same Joe's gonna go do
it forever
you think so yep interesting I'm gonna
I'm gonna say Joe will do it forever I
will tour forever
I will tour forever everything's forever
I'll do it forever I love it but that's
the thing is like it's the funnest it's
the funnest thing you could do for sure
like I understand things will ebb and
flow right but you just gotta go as hard
as you [__] can yeah
God that's so crazy yeah what is the
future that's the question what is the
future like I don't know there's a kid
right now
in ninth grade listening to this and he
goes and he just goes oh this is stupid
he goes this is so [__]
this guy's 50. you know he's drinking
Rose
this is other idiots wearing a Hawaiian
shirt and a hat yeah and usually wears
sunglasses like this because the lights
are bright and he goes I don't want to
be that person I don't want to be them
yeah I don't want to be them hold on I
brought my sunglasses oh you did put
them on and it goes and you go somebody
else someone there's someone that's
gonna look at Mark Norman wearing
sunglasses on a podcast anger we hate
him and go why why the F what are you
trying to do there's people out there
that hate us right now there's people
and that that is good that's what you
want you want you want it you want it
because it means that there's going to
be a natural that there's still passion
out there there's people that have a
hard time seeing our authenticity in
these outfits you know me and you I have
a hard time seeing our authenticity
[Music]
[Applause]
there's a there's people who I would say
they may have a uh agree because maybe
people feel like we've become like
Monsters
[Music]
maybe listen there's there's people out
there's people out there that are going
to
stupid Brooklyn they're smoking a
cigarette they're like that's what
happens when you get rich that's what
happens when you become a a successor
and they're going to become a version of
it too that's the other thing here's the
deal they'll become a version of
whatever they hate that's the ultimate
irony yeah if they're lucky enough if
they if they if they don't make it then
they can just never make it but if you
make it you'll become some version of
something you don't love because you
have to do certain things you never had
to do you have to think about marketing
you have to sit down with these people
you're right so when I got into comedy I
[__] hated
sorry I'm saying this Dane I hated that
Dane would go big secret coming on
Thursday yeah can't wait to share with
you guys I hated it yeah I hated guys
that would tell stories about themselves
yeah I was not that guy I really wasn't
I know this is going to sound I know
this is impossible for anyone listening
to hear I was not the guy that told
stories about himself at all all through
college never once did I brag about did
I tell you about the time I got involved
with the Russian mafia right there are
people that I went to college with that
do not know that story that because I
just didn't I didn't talk about myself
like that right
I was a person that was like
not I mean I just wasn't a comic but I
was like let just move forward yeah and
and then when Rolling Stone discovered
me look I'm doing it right now I'm doing
it right now I'm promoting yes when
Rolling Stone discovered me and then
they started asking questions about me
everyone had a story about me because
that's who I was I was a guy that
partied and was wild and crazy right
here by the time he took a [__] on a
pizza box to win an election right did
you hear about the time you know right
and so and then when I got into comedy I
realized oh
I don't know any of these people
no one knows that I um
crazier I have these crazy stories if I
don't talk about them on stage then
because I tried to be the [__] smart
comic right I remember the first joke I
wrote was uh because I like Mitch
Hedberg I couldn't write his jokes and I
was like what if Papa Smurf's middle
name was boner Papa boner Smurf
so bad
I did that in an alt club yeah in
overalls that's yeah that was the
beginning and I was like nothing
and that is the only joke I wrote yeah I
figured from there I could jump off
right really riff yeah
oh my God I remember that Brody Stevens
was in that room uh Barry Katz's uh
ex-wife was in that room yeah
um
ah man how awkward and then uh and then
and then I then I felt like at one point
I felt like especially
when I started doing like I was like if
I'm not telling my stories no one is and
if I'm not promoting myself no one is
and if I want to make a living at this
then I've got to get in front of it I've
got to be the guy going like and and you
know short sell like I tell you about
you know I always try to take a story
and and give you the give you the part
that like I want to casually drop it to
you like I fought a bear one time and
then someone's like wait you found a
bear and then go oh God now I got to
tell you a story it's a little trick I
do something I used to do it a lot on
radio yeah when I did radio
but I would not I would not have if I
saw me today when I started comedy I
would not have like listen when you
started you're too cool for everything
yeah and then eventually you realize not
only are you not too cool for it but
literally you're gonna have to do some
version of what a lot of other people
have done you got to promote yourself
which is the grossest thing ever but you
have to do it there's no other way
around it yeah and you know and I watch
guys not promote on purpose that's not
to move Shane Torres brilliant brilliant
brilliant comic right you put a camera
around him right and he's like your 80
year old Aunt right get it away I don't
have makeup on right and I told him I
was like we just produced this land just
produces special yeah and uh and I was
like yo we're sending you to promo Camp
right like we're gonna take you into
promo camp and teach you because there's
a part of it that goes
it's the if a tree falls in the woods
does anyone hear it she's a brilliant
comic there's a bunch of people right
now that are hearing this and go I bet
he is but do you go Google him right do
they go find his comedy do they search
him out they won't but if Shane
Stars takes charge of it take charge of
it then they see his comedy and then all
of a sudden they get a brilliant comic
that they get to fall in love with
that's the beauty of promotion but it is
the whoreness of it is like I watch the
whole year you become a little bit of a
disgusting Pig [__] and if you and if
you don't
I mean I've always tried to lean in to
just show them where the pig lays that's
right like put on a speedo show the
[__] learning dance moves yes [__]
bring a marching band out yeah just let
them know that I am aware I'm promoting
yeah but I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm I'm not gonna be like
like there's not a lot of cool ways to
promote uh so you gotta go big I mean
you gotta go big and you're gonna not
care it doesn't really matter okay I'll
tell you what you can't do right I mean
I'll give you the ins and outs of what
you can't do phone up guys so crazy
right we sold out the first show
I I we're adding a second show this is
insane you got like that energy right
it's it's it's it's like when I first
started doing uh Myspace yeah and I
remember you'd go like uh I'm out I'm in
Brea tonight yeah and there was a
difference between saying I'll be in
Brea tonight versus I'll be headlining
in Brea tonight right because then
everyone's like oh you don't normally
headline I might go and see that show
right like if you put that I'm
headlining then you're like but
there's something cool to be proud of it
like stavi just sold six shows in at the
Vic great in Chicago yeah dude
I'll tell you what and this is my two
cents yeah but him saying I sold six
shows in at the Vic in in Chicago such
an amazing weekend I'll see you this
weekend New Orleans and wherever he was
yeah I remember the cities because I go
oh if I was in that City I'd go see him
he just sold six at the Vic right like
that's a cool way to go about it I think
everyone's got their own little
authentic thumbprint yeah and I think
once you find your thumbprint then you
can talk to your fans a little bit yes
yes I mean that that's a hundred percent
the case yours has always been a little
more humble and like and like almost
low-key almost like you and Shane Gillis
are the same way like Shane will be like
and there will be a point and I there
was a moment where I was I got a nice
Cruise where I was like
I do a promo video to start the tour
yeah sell them out and be like all right
you won't hear from me again yeah you go
to Arenas and you're like oh there's
always tickets yeah you gotta always
there's always always yeah I mean I
think with my thing is just like some
people you're so creative with it I'm
not as creative with it so what I do is
kind of like we cut really fun promos
for things that are funny and kind of
specific to the region because my show
no matter what I have my jokes I'm gonna
talk about where I am yeah so there's
gonna be things you don't hear that are
jokes like so San Francisco or Long
Island like there's gonna be I'm you
know that's what I'm doing with you
that's what I do to you it's what I do
it's like I have an interest in places
like if I do Oklahoma City there's 10
minutes on Oklahoma City yeah if I do
San Francisco there's maybe 15 minutes
on San Francisco like I love that idea
of walking around the place putting
together my thoughts and you know
workshopping them a little bit maybe
working them out on a podcast but like
making it a show that is specific to
where I'm at at the moment like that
it's also it's also as a fan as a fan of
yours yeah it's what I enjoy like coming
here today I was like I know how your
brain works yeah and so I go your brain
never shuts down it never shuts down you
have something you're always writing
some analogy or some rant on something
and I was like I'm not writing at all
right
I literally was like I gotta start
writing I was literally like in the car
going
what do we do about how do we get an
analogy about Austin University
well and you did it and that was
beautifully done yeah it was beautifully
done you're the only person in America
dude that has not moved to Austin Texas
you're the only one well it's the
coolest place to do comedy it is really
cool
that's [__] I mean listen it's
a fun for me I love it it's a fun
frequent visit it's I'll tell you what I
I had the most fun the most fun the club
is the most fun comedy Mothership and I
I'm man it's done you know I would 100
Joe's balls no it's done even in a funny
way it's done perfectly it's done
perfectly it's not perfect it's a comic
put together the perfect common code
that's right so and and what's going to
be cool is you know the city
if I worked with the urban planners I'm
a city planner
the comedy club's phenomenal comedy
club's amazing it's great I love I love
going there Leanne and I were talking so
we just bought a tour bus and we were
talking about finding buying a place in
Austin I didn't actually talked to Joe
about getting his realtor buying a place
in Austin
and then getting a place on the lake and
putting the tour bus so the place tour
bus has somewhere centrally located to
be interesting yeah and it's not a bad
idea we may still do it I mean I wish
I'd bought a place
uh a year ago two years ago when you
bought a place yeah I wish I bought a
place then because I'm there all the
time yeah they're a lot and I literally
was as you said like I still have a
house there I was like maybe we yeah
well maybe I could stay there when I
come yeah absolutely can the thing that
was smart is that um
you know it's it's a good investment to
have a spot there I wish I bought then I
I look I I when I go there I I only see
one hotel and two bears the yma studios
and Rogan's the place now I get to go to
now I'm glad the company mothership's
open because
it's it's it was either I did one night
there and I had the most fun I've I've
ever had on stage yeah the only other
time I've done a comedy club was Comedy
on State which is the [__] best it's
amazing and I [__] loved comedy
membership in my opinion was better than
comedy on stage yeah it was amazing and
that's hard to say because coming on
stays the best right I they wanted me to
tell the machine story and I was like
I'm absolutely not telling it and they
started going crazy and I knew Ron White
was upstairs and I said I'll tell it if
Ron White comes down and tells tater
salad oh interesting and wrong and
everyone's like loses their [__] they're
like Ron whites here right and then Ron
White's like I'm coming oh wow he came
down on stage told Tater South he hadn't
told it in years oh my God I'm told in
years like FaceTime Lee and Leanne's
favorite Comics Ron White yeah Ron White
and Bernie Mac yeah and so uh I I played
I let her watch it on the phone it was
[__] epic yeah it was epic and and
you know the thing that Joe's got going
for
mothership is that we're all going to
come down to do his podcast all the time
all the time all the time we're all well
I'll also go down there all the time
because the club's amazing and it's a
great place to build stuff and work out
yeah that's great and I want to do the
small room yeah small room is fun yeah I
mean it's look
maybe okay
Austin is like a husband who won't stop
asking for anal sex
that's possibly true where you're like
something's wrong we're like we're like
what is going on with it like like every
time I talk to Joe and Tom they're like
come on man come on man let me just try
it let me just put the two pack that is
the craziest
like what is going on with it what is
going on with this guy that just keeps
running yeah bringing it up like [__]
I'll let you do it when I want to do it
right let me call you and say hey can I
get my earrings yeah yeah yeah yeah no
they I mean they seem to love it but
they love it and and listen Tom loves it
Tom's Tom would be happy in [__]
anywhere in the world you can put time
or I've warmed up to it here's my
problem I Come From New York
it ruins you for life yeah when you grow
up well you were also there during the
ice storm
well but that I mean I remember your
yeah I remember that was my favorite was
your I don't know if it was your
Instagram or your Twitter during the ice
storm yeah you're like oh good call Joe
yeah it was freezing but uh listen I
will say this coming from New York you
just get spoiled man yeah you it's all
kinds of different people it's really
cool it's everything you could want in a
place as a city you're just meeting all
kinds of interesting people all the time
yeah and food or whatever it's like
there is something I said when it coming
to La was a massive adjustment then I
just think going to Texas was a little
it was too much
you are doing you do I I'm envious of
the way you do la yeah you do la right I
do it right you do it [__] I do it
right I was telling someone the other
day I was telling my I don't know who I
was telling now that I say it but I was
like uh
he goes to like muso and Franks and Nobu
yes and the polo yeah Polo Lounge yeah
that's the way you're supposed to do it
that's right he rolls up thick yeah in a
150 000 car yeah and [__] with a with
a with a Hawaiian shirt yeah shorts and
sneakers on yeah and and that's the way
you're supposed to do la I think he's
supposed to look like a big toddler
you're both you're supposed to like a
big Rich dumb toddler no respect yes
that's really if you're if you're not
doing la like that New York you're in
like boots and you're like cool and
you're downtown scarf out scarf La
you're supposed to look like you just
got out of a youth hostel yes like
you're out of a mental institution like
they can't tell if you're going into
into rehab or out of rehab I've sat next
to the best restaurants in this city
I've sat next to somebody in a lime
green onesie who was like an adult I
love it yeah that's what I love about it
that's what I like about the West that's
what I've always strived for in the city
is to look ridiculous to look stupid and
be ridiculous I remember going to
restaurant when
um because once you start doing this
it's hard to go back I get up and I wear
ridiculous stuff and I walk around and
it's all fine I don't know if I could go
back to New York where I'm like I want
to look smart oh I couldn't feel I don't
I gotta lose weight if I want to go
there I will grip both on both counts I
agree with you but to me I'm like
there's something fun about
dressing like like someone with a real
problem I went to a restaurant one time
when I was younger
and I said what's the dress code and the
guy said you can't wear a t-shirt
and flip-flops
and I said but that guy this is in La I
said but that guy's in the t-shirt and
flip-flops yeah and he goes yeah but he
didn't ask what the dress code was
interesting that's great so wait what's
that mean for me and he goes you had to
ask so you're not allowed in right I was
like Wow get me to the place where I no
longer ask yeah I remember that was like
a game changer for me the way I looked
at things I was like yeah because I
don't I'm not really comfortable in a
lot of clothes yeah so I'm like I'm
really I'm I have tactile issues and so
and t-shirts and flip-flops and jeans
that's my that's what I wear every
single day yeah I can tell you the exact
jeans the exact t-shirt and my
flip-flops that are available on uh
freewaters.com
but uh
that was like I remember looking at him
going like oh [__]
okay so that's La yeah la is the place
where and look I'm sure Joe would hear
this and roll his eyes and be like [__]
that guy [__] La you know like right but
like I like that energy it's a fun
energy it's an interesting energy to
have in a city where you're allowed it I
also like my favorite thing about La is
that it's collapsing yeah and I'll tell
you oh it is collapsing it's collapsing
and I like that because it's exhausting
to live in you know Hillary Clinton lost
because she had an air of inevitability
people hate that this idea that
something's gonna have to happen yes
it's exhausting yes so the Austin to me
a little bit and Charlotte I mean I'm
not Charlotte in Nashville and Miami all
these places when you go to them like I
lived in New York I live in the greatest
city in the world do you know what
a New Yorker would say to you if you
said [__] this city sucks they turn
around and go you have no idea how much
it sucks yeah you let me tell you how
much it sucks for 10 minutes you don't
even [__] know we should it was the
greatest place in the world it's the the
best our country could do I was a tour
guide in New York City people from all
over the world went all over this
country and went this is truly
impressive LA's fine there's a few other
things Yellowstone's beautiful but as a
city yeah this is it and we would [__]
on it we would sit on it New Yorkers
would [__] on it there's something
exhausting about a place where people
all feel like they're all read the same
brochure oh yeah I don't like that
there's as a comic I love the the as a
comedian yeah there's something about
ripping things apart that's attractive
to me not building them up we should get
Courtside Lakers tickets yes 100 and we
should be those guys and dressed like
Psychopaths dress like Psychopaths yes
when's basketball start this is how bad
of a [__]
is basketball coming soon it's going on
right now oh [__] time right now next
year next year you don't know you'll
never be I mean you have so you're so
many Road dates well let's let's you
slow down at all coming up like to you
are you is there a period where you go
during the summer do you go like I take
a little bit no
no the the one the one the one uh
caveat I have is that fully loaded
um
Leanne Isla in Georgia will be on the
road with us that's great so there so
we'll all be a family on the road which
is awesome amazing there's catering
right there's [__] gyms there's polar
plunges right we're Outdoors we're
indoors we can do everything we have two
days off in between we have Monday
Tuesday off or Monday Tuesday Wednesday
off so we can hang out in different
cities right it's going to be great
fully loaded I'm telling you it's for me
yeah that's a cheat code for me yeah I
mean we don't we don't I don't take any
money from our door deal we put it all
back into the festival because then it's
like the only way this is successful is
if in 11 years we sell it to like
Budweiser right and she's like in order
to get there in 11 years you can't make
money right for the first [__] ten
right you gotta make money on 11 where
everyone's like well this is inevitable
this is undeniable right
um so that's the big thing for me is uh
I'll do that I'm already double booked
for the fall I'm literally I have three
projects I'm supposed to do and then I
have a tour lined up that we haven't
announced but I think I don't know
what's gonna happen for the fall
to watch it is amazing oh well to watch
your speed and pace is wild well I
appreciate it I I don't uh
you know what I feel like I've gotten to
a place where I
I don't know I I don't know I don't know
how to respond to that because I go
thank you yeah I know that people I
would listen to a podcast today where
some guy was kind of [__] on me Loki
[__] on me like
all he does is work and I felt like
going like yeah but but you don't right
like I'm looking at your career this guy
thinks he shows up and he does one
podcast a week and maybe does a weekend
and then he's making something I go
buddy now you gotta step up your [__]
game
yes like I don't want to name I'm not
gonna name the guy but I was like
being good at comedy is not everything
no you got to do everything you gotta
[__] hustle you gotta like you gotta
work you gotta work and and uh and I
just think that the only thing I am in
control of is working it's so funny I
used to [__] on Kevin Hart for it yeah I
used to not even Loki I was [__] on
Kevin Hartford because I was like
we all work hard and it's true anyone
listening to this right now is like
driving a truck to go dig a hole and
it's like trust me dig a hole it's hard
[__] work right but like I always
want to isolate the luck like I want to
find the luck in the thing that happens
for you so whether you're digging the
hole and then all of a sudden one day
guy's like hey man can you help me like
my dad I'll give him for example my dad
was a lawyer in Florida for a very long
time and the one uh one day a guy from
Miami called up and said hey I do this
thing it's kind of like
it's it's it's a little bit looked down
upon but I I do closings for homes as a
lawyer
um normally like when you close on a
home there's a place like Chicago Title
that'll close on a home and they'll hire
a lawyer
and we'll get that lawyer fee what I do
is as a lawyer I just do the closing
myself and then I I get the closing fees
and then I I waive the lawyer fee
because I'm the lawyer I'm already there
but can you do that for me I've become a
couple coming up from Miami and my dad's
like yeah sure and he did it close on
their home for them and waived his
lawyer fee and then my dad was like oh
that's interesting it's really good
business like it's I mean yeah I'm not
technically getting money as a lawyer
but I'm making money in this closing fee
and then my dad started doing that and
then my dad turned that into a business
and sold his business for a lump sum to
Chicago Title right but it was looked
down upon with by other Comics or other
uh lawyers lawyers because he wasn't he
wasn't in court he wasn't like fighting
cases
but I remember my dad made a good amount
of money after that and I remember
looking at that little bit of luck that
one phone call if he hadn't answered the
phone all right and I'd look at that for
me all the time yeah and I wanted to
know what it was for Kevin Hart that's
the thing I would do a whole podcast on
luck just finding out the one thing
for me it was I'd written something
about the Louis CK stuff a lot of people
it was a fever pitch and I wrote
something about it and it was just
basically like Louie's a great comedian
you could think whatever but I mean
there were people saying oh and you know
what he wasn't that funny or when it was
stupid and I wrote it on Facebook and
Ari shafir showed that to Joe Rogan who
messaged me on Instagram and said this
is really good this is really
brilliantly but and I said thanks Joe
thank you that was it oh and then he
messaged gangster [__] move yeah
thanks a lot I really appreciate it he
messaged me again or I messaged him
again because he mentioned me on a show
and he said something nice I said thanks
for the mention really appreciate it he
goes let me know when you're in La we'll
do a podcast and then eventually we did
that was my Stroke of Luck
that was The Stroke of Luck that's the
thing I mean that was the second stroke
of luck I think the first stroke of lock
was I was doing well in a comedy show in
Brooklyn Chris gethard was there he got
his manager to look at me who signed me
I ended up getting the Montreal Comedy
Festival I killed a dad I did really
well there I got an agent shout out to
Hillary who's angry at me because I
called her fat honey stop and
she was really good and I said to her
when I sat down at JFL in 2016 I said I
want to be on the road I said put me on
the road I want to learn how to be a
comedian put me on the road all this
other [__] the scripts to this that
that's all great and we'll do all that
too get me on the road 1500 seven shows
don't give a [__] the next week or the
next month I was in San Antonio doing
seven shows for no money and I was like
let's keep this going and that was the
then I kept doing that up until
Joe allowed me to do his
podcast and it was you know we hit it
off and and I was you know I was really
lucky there's luck there's luck and then
there's uh approaching luck like my luck
oddly enough
my luck is Tom
waiting on Charlie Murphy
interesting because Tom was doing a show
with Joe and Charlie Murphy Charlie
Murphy is like yo let's go to dinner
Tom's like all right and Charlie Murphy
was taking a while he was a little late
yeah and Joe was standing there and or
Thomas sitting there and Joe walked past
him and was like Hey man you're really
funny Tom's like oh thanks and
I think Tom explains it better but he
was like I just was gonna just leave but
I just I was waiting right and he's like
I don't even think we went to dinner
that night but he waited and he met Joe
and then I honestly think because I was
good friends with Tom at the time
when uh when Ari and Tom were in the car
and Joe had heard the uh Tracy Morgan
story he was like God man that's a great
story and they're like oh that's birth
story
and then he's like who's Bert and Todd
not been in the car you know Ari's not
yeah a very effective human in moments
right like he's not the guy that like
he's not messing people up yeah he's
usually just high in the back just like
kind of like I remember Ari one time was
like Hey man someone was telling one of
your stories on stage I go who and he
goes I don't know
what did you say and he's like nothing
yeah like why didn't you say something
and he was like I don't know right so
like but like I look at that because
through that then Joe messaged me and
Joe's I mean Joe's a lot of our luck
he's a huge amount of luck for all of us
I mean it you could you could ale you
could isolate
almost everyone's luck and connected
there should be a thing yeah Six Degrees
of Joe Rogan yeah I mean oh that was my
big time luck like 100 because I I had I
had that was the biggest platform I'd
ever been asked to be on and you were so
[__] perfectly well we I love the guy
like we we became really good friends
and like he's a really fun guy to talk
to and like me and him were being funny
and like we liked a lot of the same
we're interested in a lot of the same
[__] you guys are dialed into a lot of
the same [__] we dialed into it I don't
have a lot of the same interests as he
has you you're they're different
interests probably no they're not I
don't even know if we have any interest
or just stand-up comedy I mean honestly
I go like I don't know harambe I don't
know like right like I don't know that I
don't know uh anything political right I
don't know anything about uh
psychedelics or space right Jiu Jitsu
like I wonder why he likes me
I think he likes you because you're he
loves comedians he loves comedy and he
loves people that build stuff and you
built something and I think that's
probably why
he respects that like I didn't know who
I didn't know who Alex Jones was until
way too far that's funny like I remember
one time I walked into the I walked into
the Green Room of the store yeah
someone's like hey bird when are you
gonna have Alex Jones on and I was like
[__] never right right and it was
Alex Jones
and I was like I didn't even know who he
was
by the way I could never have a mom
because you know I would just green
light everything yeah you go that sounds
great I would green light everything
he's a fascinating guy he's I I him and
Donald Trump and Caitlyn Jenner are my
three Caitlyn Jenner's a gangster
they're my American meaning they're the
most American lives of all time in my
opinion in this era dude Alex Jones you
can't who are your three Caitlyn Jenner
Caitlyn Jenner and Donald Trump the most
American like because if you look at all
of their lives you go this doesn't
really work in another country like a
specifically American country like a
Gold Medal decathlete winner marries a
momager of the most successful family of
of of Instagram thoughts that's ever
lived father got OJ acquitted OJ
acquitted that's a movie it's a movie
it's not real it's crazy that's crazy
it's crazy then if you look at like
Trump this guy who was a a wrestling
heel and a gay show host on television a
reality star ends up becoming the
president of the United States as a gag
as like a bit Yeah that's the most
that's another movie and then the third
movie is a guy like Alex Jones who
started out in Austin yelling at cops
because he thought the Dewey checkpoints
were unconstitutional ends up somehow
you're becoming an enemy he's been an
enemy and an ally of everyone on every
side at one point yeah he hated the
bushes and then you know and the right
wing hated him when I grew up they hated
him and now they like him because he was
friendly with Trump but like he was this
guy that threw out his career
became his own one-man Media Company
it's in the only country and and then
had it all like kind of now he owes a
billion dollars because yeah well how's
he who knows I don't think it's I mean I
don't think they're gonna get they're
not gonna he doesn't have it for them to
get so it's what happens like I don't
even know I don't either a child I am I
don't even know what happens to his life
I mean there's his cars he has to give
him a lot of things and then I guess
they there's a certain amount of money
he's allowed to earn and then they take
all the rest I imagine that's how
judgments work but of those three people
I go could that have happened in Sweden
like none of those people's lives are
possible in any other country except
America like you look at the British
people and it's like so the Royals but
if you're outside of the Royals there's
no it's not you know I would have loved
have been a royal oh God it would have
been amazing that's why Meghan Markle we
knew she was kind of full of [__] do you
remember brand new you called me yeah
yeah you called me and I was like this
is [__] Meghan Markle the my
favorite Royals Prince Philip
interesting yeah quiet dignity oh a
quiet dignity Prince Philip he lived
Bachelor parties Princess Beatrice which
one's that get up Princess Beatrice
she's a little she's a fun she would be
fully loaded
if there's somebody had fully loaded
it's her no who is she she's she's no
model but she is she likes to throw a
few back
Beatrice likes she's a little scary up
front whoa but I mean she likes to throw
a few back and she always looks a little
I mean I'm assuming she'll never hear
this but what the [__] well they're
inbred yeah
but this shows let me see the I love
that they just post the bad pictures up
front no I want to see the top one where
she looks like she's [__] Skeletor
up at the top right top right top right
top right there one that one oh it's
scary what the [__] terrifying
now go to princess Eugenia
this is hers Eugenia is a little better
Eugenie she's a little better and who
are they related to uh there's Eugene
who knows they're I don't know their
he's better she's better
thin bread simbredi it is it is
the uh no no no doubt did you watch the
crown a little bit of it I couldn't get
up there but I loved it you know I only
like I only watch for Princess Prince
Philip I gotta try it again he was the
best he would just go to an island and
be like bring out the light-skinned ones
I'll [__] them first amazing and then
they'd be laying around with just
indigenous people and they're like
Prince Philip we got an SOS
your your something died and you'd be
like damn it oh
kill the ones I came in let's go yeah he
really you know you but you've created a
way to kind of Be An American Royal in
your own way oh kind of please think
about it please I love when you pitch me
yeah do you remember one time I was
telling you I was up in panic attacks
and you go why
it's the best it's ever gonna be today
you're making more money than you've
ever made you're selling more tickets no
one told you you had to quit drinking
your family's alive it never gets better
than today and I went you changed my
[__] mind no it was it because it's
me I'm being a royal here's why I think
you are a royal you Traverse the country
with a Cavalry you have your own meat
like this is the way Royals used to do
it you travel around with your own you
know Cavalry you have a chariot that you
own your own Chariot okay all right I'm
Prince Philip you are received when you
go to a place you're received by adoring
masses I am Prince Philip and you do
this all while enjoying the spoils of a
glass of wine
cocktail or a feast
this is you can drink whatever I want I
gotta put on fancy clothes at the end of
the night if you describe Describe the
life of a royal to someone who had been
on the planet a few minutes and you
described your life they would go oh
he's a royal he comes into town with the
Cavalry the adoring masses are there he
will Feast he will drink
God damn it Tim you're good I mean
that's the truth you've figured out a
way to be an American Royal now it's
because America and Americans have a
fifth grade reading level
but your kid now
I'm kingro you're King Ralph prayer
Crusher you are one of the it's amazing
to see you what you've done your insane
I where can people buy these tickets
uh uh fully loaded
is the festival that starts his fall I
don't know when this comes out I only
have one weekend left it's next weekend
and I think they're all sold out effort
tops off The Machine movie is out
Memorial Day Weekend go to the machine
dot movie we've set it up so that we can
pre-buy tickets for a live in theater
event that'll stream directly into the
theaters from the red carpet I hope
you'll be at the Red Carpet I'd love to
be at the Red Carpet I would love to be
then then everyone go get your tickets
for that Thursday show we're doing a
Premiere Thursday and uh and we will be
streaming from the red carpet I don't
know I don't know what capacity it'll be
but I think what we'll do is we'll have
everyone that is coming stream right
into the movie theaters for the first
baby hour yeah uh go to the
machine.movie uh like I said fully
loaded the cruise is sold out uh tickets
are available we start in Forest Hills
we got Tiffany Addis Lewis Black
um amazing yeah and it's it's the Rupp
Arena uh Little Caesars oh that's me
this weekend yeah those are all done
and then uh yeah I mean amazing you've
just I mean it's like I've been on the
road a lot you've been on the road a ton
more than me but it's like it is
interesting it is an interesting we see
more of the country than most people
will I and I I mean dude the Most
Blessed I ever was was during the
pandemic yeah they would go out in the
country during the pandemic and see what
the world was like that's right gives
you a little bit different the most
intense thing I ever did was the Alex
Jones podcast with Joe a week before the
election during the pandemic in Austin
wow so Austin whether I hate it or love
it it's a huge part of my life oh it's a
huge part of my life I'm there literally
once a month it's a huge part of my life
I know I mean I know Austin I I would
argue better than Tom yeah because he
says they're as much as it's like in
Iceland half the time dude I'll reach
out to nadav I'm like can I podcast with
them he's like he's in Reykjavik I'm
like what was he doing ironing out an
agreement he [__] he's dead inside
the uh well you know what that could be
said for many of us yeah we better keep
Dancing Keep dancing because we better
keep it you know there was a great it
was a great there's a great quote
there's black jazz musician older guy
and there was this young Jazz kid white
kid and he comes into uh
it's jazz club in New York City called
Smalls famous jazz club and the young
white kids like really enthusiastic and
everything and he's talking about like
how he's going to do this and that and
this that and the other thing man and
the black the black guy just laughed and
he goes and then he goes what are you
laughing at and he goes you better love
the music
you know he just laughs because you
better love the music because it's all
this other [__] the kid was saying was
just like ancillary and like he was just
like you better love the music man he
goes and the kid goes oh interesting and
then I talked to that guy later and he's
like I fully understood what he meant a
few years later like at the end of the
day it's not really about the money it's
not about this clout it's not about any
of the [__] it's literally about do
you love the music Do You Love
putting out stuff that people laugh at
and whether you do it on the Internet or
whether you do it on stage or whether
you do it wherever you do it do you love
that and you have to love it because if
you're doing it for anything else all
those other things will fade away but if
you love what you're actually doing
you'll do it forever the feeling
I wish I could give this I was I was
saying this about
chefs the other day I love making food
for people right I love it I love I love
making people happy I love that's what I
love about stand up is right when I make
people laugh it makes me feel good like
I go I'm giving I'm I'm it's like
feeding them there's a similar feeling
but the thing I love more than anything
is the moment you figure it out not
the the not the time you kill with the
bit it's the time where you say it a
little off but you figure it out the
before you kill with the [__] that's
right so like the time where you go oh
[__] if I say this different next show
it's gonna murder that moment for me is
everything I love about stand up that
moment and I look for that that moment
the only example I can give is is the
first time I I didn't have an end to the
machine and I said uh I said um
she opens door you come with us he spits
vodka in her face and uh looks at me and
goes
and the first time I went he looks at me
and goes [__] that [__] this is Russia
that moment where I went I have an end
of the story now that moment is the
grass the music for me is like I wanted
you to do that that I wanted to hear at
the end I wanted you to do some version
of like [__] this is Texas [__] this
[__] this is awesome yeah this is
Austin and then the whole the whole
place would have completely but the
other part is like and look I don't know
no one will get to know what you may
enjoy that rant about me being a royal
yeah but you'll never enjoy it as much
as the guy sitting across from the guy
right who did it yeah and that's the
beauty of Comedy it's like I get to hang
out I said the silly end of the day
my friends are literally the funniest
human beings in the world yeah in the
world I can call up I can call up the
funniest people in the world except for
a couple I think they hate me but I can
call up the funniest people in the world
and
and laugh at any moment about anything
I'm on a text thread I'm on a text
thread with big J Dan Soder Ari shaffir
salvokano Nate bargatzi and
two other people two other comics and
the chapter it's called [__] and all
we've said to each other is we're not
there yet I'm not there yet I'm on my
way
and it's we don't remember where the
threat is from that's so fun and today
Ari goes I'm on my way he's just on the
way here he goes I'm on my way and I
said I'm five minutes out and soda wrote
I don't think I'm gonna make it ah it's
so funny grown-ups don't do that now we
get to live these crazy lives like I
think that's a huge yeah where you have
I've they're all adults they're all
adults with health insurance and life
insurance right and they're and we're
all continually texting about some where
we'll never go that's right and like
it's the [__] best and I'm drinking
rose on a [__] Monday in Beverly
Hills Beverly Hills it does life get
better it doesn't get better I killed
the ones I came in Kill the ones he came
in Brooke Chrysler fully loaded go get
tickets he's
he's doing it forever I love you brother
all right love you too thank you